OK. Of everything in pop culture, what can make a teenage boy cry? That's a very specialized list, right? And we got to talking about this at our office because Lina Misitzis, one of the producers here, remembers how there was this one video game, a PlayStation game, that got her brother and his friends when they were kids. She says he was definitely not a crier.
好的。在流行文化的一切事物中，有什么能让一个十几岁的男孩哭泣？这是一个非常特别的清单，对吧？我们在办公室谈论过这个话题，因为这里的制片人之一莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）记得，有一款电子游戏，一款PlayStation游戏，曾让她的哥哥和他的朋友们在孩提时代为之落泪。她说他绝对不是一个爱哭的人。
And honestly in my memory of it, my brother Yannos cries halfway through the game because this character dies. He actually says that that's not true. But one of his other friends also remembers him crying. And lots of people had this reaction to the character's death, like famously. No matter how you play the game, she always dies, and people reacted.
老实说，在我的记忆中，我哥哥亚诺斯（Yannos）在游戏进行到一半时哭了，因为这个角色死了。他实际上说那不是真的。但他的一位朋友也记得他哭了。很多人对这个角色的死亡都有这种反应，这很出名。无论你怎么玩这个游戏，她总是会死，而人们对此做出了反应。
What was the game?
那是什么游戏？
It's called Final Fantasy VII.
它叫《最终幻想VII》。
When was this?
这是什么时候的事？
1997. And the character that they're all crying over is named Aeris, but some people call her Aerith.
1997年。他们都为之哭泣的那个角色叫爱丽丝（Aeris），但有些人叫她爱丽丝（Aerith）。
And what was it about this character that was so intense?
这个角色到底有什么特别之处，让人如此激动？
Well, OK. So I have no idea. To me, it made no sense. She's like this one-dimensional girl. She's a cartoon. At the time, it was a big deal that she was 3D. So she looked, I guess, believable, but she kind of looks like a Mario character. It doesn't make sense to me that all of these boys would cry over it.
嗯，好吧。我不知道。对我来说，这毫无意义。她就像那种单维度的女孩。她是个卡通人物。在当时，她是3D的这一点很了不起。所以我猜她看起来很真实，但她看起来有点像马里奥里的角色。所有这些男孩为之哭泣，这对我来说毫无意义。
And so since my brother disagrees that he cried about it, I called someone who definitely did. His name is Mike Fahey. He's a writer for Kotaku, this video game review and reporting website. And he wrote about Final Fantasy VII being remade. It comes out, I think, in the next year or two. And he wrote this article, and the title of the article was, "I Can't Go Through This Again."
既然我哥哥不同意他为此哭过，我给一个绝对哭过的人打了电话。他的名字叫迈克·法伊（Mike Fahey）。他是Kotaku的撰稿人，这是一个电子游戏评论和报道网站。他写了一篇关于《最终幻想VII》重制版即将推出的文章。我想是在未来一两年内发行。他写了那篇文章，标题是“我无法再经历一次”。
About this scene?
关于这一幕吗？
About this scene. About this scene. It's about how he doesn't feel like he can deal with her dying two times in his life. One time was enough.
关于这一幕。关于这一幕。这是关于他觉得无法在有生之年再次面对她的死亡。经历一次就够了。
It was a big part of my youth. I mean, it was, what, 22 years ago I played this game. And I still remember that particular moment.
这是我青春中很大的一部分。我是说，我玩这个游戏已经是，嗯，22年前的事了。我仍然记得那个特定的时刻。
He's in his 40s now, but then he was like-- I don't know-- 24. And he's on his couch playing the game.
他现在40多岁了，但当时他大概是……我不知道……24岁。他坐在沙发上玩这个游戏。
It felt like there was no real lead into it. I might have even had my attention wandering while the cut scene was playing. And then all of a sudden, there's a giant sword in her. Sephiroth comes down, impales her, and you're like, no. This has to change. This has to stop. My stomach fell. I remember my stomach just falling and feeling like it was just dropping in my chest. And that music kicks in just as she's dying. And whenever I hear that music, I just tear right up.
感觉就像没有任何铺垫。当过场动画播放时，我的注意力甚至可能已经不集中了。然后突然间，一把巨大的剑刺穿了她。萨菲罗斯（Sephiroth）降临，刺穿了她，你会想，不。这必须改变。这必须停止。我的胃沉了下去。我记得我的胃部下沉，感觉就像它在胸腔里坠落一样。当她死去时，那段音乐响起了。每当我听到那段音乐，我就禁不住流泪。
And Ira, this is what the scene looks like.
艾拉（Ira），这就是那一幕的样子。
All right, hold on. Let's put this up. OK, you're now watching a video that we're seeing online.
好了，等一下。让我们放出来。好的，你现在正在观看我们在线看到的视频。
OK, so you're the protagonist. You're Cloud. His name is Cloud Strife.
好的，你是主角。你是克劳德（Cloud）。他的名字叫克劳德·斯特莱夫（Cloud Strife）。
So that's the character with the orange hair.
所以那就是那个橘色头发的角色。
Uh, yeah. I mean, it's yellow, but you can call it orange. It's his job to protect her.
呃，是啊。我是说，它是黄色的，但你可以叫它橘色。保护她是他的职责。
And so they're standing on some sort of platform. There's mist all over the place.
他们正站在某种平台上。到处都是雾。
Yeah, and you can see this girl up here. That's Aeris. Can you see what she's doing?
是啊，你可以看到这个女孩在这。那是爱丽丝。你能看到她在做什么吗？
Oh, she's kneeling-- praying?
哦，她在跪着——祈祷吗？
She's praying, yeah.
她在祈祷，是的。
She's praying. She has long hair braided in a bow, I guess. Pink dress. She looks up. Cloud looks back at her, very dramatic. Oh, a menacing figure in a cape drops down.
她在祈祷。我猜她有一头扎成蝴蝶结的长发。粉红色的裙子。她抬头看。克劳德回头看她，非常戏剧化。哦，一个披着斗篷的险恶身影降落了。
So I had Mike watch this with me when I talked to him.
所以我让迈克和我一起看了这段视频，当我采访他的时候。
Wait, he wrote a whole article saying, I can't go through this again, and you made him watch it again?
等等，他写了一整篇文章说“我无法再经历一次”，然后你让他又看了一遍？
Uh, yeah, he was fine. It was just a video clip.
呃，是的，他没事。那只是个视频片段。
And here we go. Sephiroth plunges from the heavens. Oh my god.
我们开始了。萨菲罗斯从天而降。天哪。
I have to say, it's very sudden.
我得说，这非常突然。
And she just slumps over like that, and her eyes are still open. Her mouth parts just a little bit. This is right about where the music starts. And is when the tears start to fall. Ugh, I mean, there's that moment of shock when that sword goes through her. And then, "This can't be real."
她就这样瘫倒了，眼睛还睁着。嘴巴微微张开。这差不多就是音乐开始的地方。也是眼泪开始流下的时刻。呃，我是说，当那把剑穿过她时，那一刻的震惊感。然后，“这不可能是真的。”
He's reading off the screen.
他在读屏幕上的字。
Cloud says, "This can't be real." And that's really what everyone was feeling right there. That line right there, "Aeris will no longer talk, no longer laugh, cry, or get angry." Oh my god. [SNIFFLES] OK. Damn it. "His fingers are tingling, his mouth is dry. His eyes are burning." I'm right there with him. Yeah, I'm tearing up.
克劳德说，“这不可能是真的。”这确实是当时每个人在那里的感受。那一句话，“爱丽丝再也不会说话、大笑、哭泣或生气了。”天哪。[抽泣]好吧。该死。“他的手指在发麻，嘴巴很干。他的眼睛在燃烧。”我和他感同身受。是的，我流泪了。
OK, so why of all the characters in all the video games in the world, why do they tear up for this girl?
好吧，那么在世界上所有的电子游戏中，为什么偏偏是这个角色，为什么他们会为这个女孩流泪？
Well, in part, it's because it's one of the first times it's happened. I mean, it was just like a surprise. It was really new. And to clarify, Mike knows that Aeris is just this one-dimensional character. The official game description of her is literally, quote, "young, beautiful, and somewhat mysterious."
嗯，部分原因是这是它第一次发生。我是说，这就像一个惊喜。这真的很新颖。澄清一下，迈克知道爱丽丝只是一个单维度的角色。游戏中对她的官方描述实际上是，引述，“年轻、美丽且有点神秘。”
Wait. Could we pause on the word, "somewhat"? That seems so weirdly insulting. Like, well, you're just somewhat mysterious.
等等。我们能暂停一下“有点”这个词吗？这看起来太奇怪地具有侮辱性了。就像是，嗯，你只是有点神秘。
[LAUGHS] OK. Right. And in the game, she really does just two things. She stands next to people and calms them down. Like she'll put her hand on someone's chest in this meaningful way. She's this reassuring presence, this healer. And then the other thing she does is she asks for help.
[笑]好的。没错。在游戏中，她确实只做了两件事。她站在人们身边安抚他们。就像她会以一种意味深长的方式把手放在某人的胸口。她是一种令人安心的存在，这个治疗者。然后她做的另一件事是请求帮助。
So that's the two basic female functions, right?
所以这就是基本的女性功能，对吧？
It's like fix and help. Fix and help.
就像修理和帮助。修理和帮助。
Right. OK.
没错。好的。
And Mike knows all of this. But he says that's enough. It's enough about her to make you, the protagonist, care.
迈克知道这一切。但他认为这已经足够了。关于她的足够多，能让你，也就是主角，去关心她。
She sort of is one-dimensional. She's like the ray of hope. She grows flowers in this disgusting slum. She's almost like a billboard that things can be better. Her sweetness and lightness is what they're really trying to squeeze out of her. So that's what they focus on. And she's understanding. And maybe that's why one of the other reasons you feel for her. Because you feel kind of like she would understand you.
她算是一个单维度的角色。她就像一丝希望的曙光。她在这些肮脏的贫民窟里种花。她几乎就像一个“事情会好起来”的广告牌。她的甜美和轻盈才是他们真正想从她身上榨取的东西。所以这就是他们关注的重点。而且她很善解人意。也许这就是你同情她的另一个原因。因为你觉得她好像会理解你。
Also, of course, she's pretty.
而且，当然，她很漂亮。
Yeah, she's adorable. She really is. It's those big blue eyes. They bore into you, really. They're in my head, and they have been for 20 years. They're blue, aren't they?
是的，她很可爱。她确实如此。是那双蓝色的大眼睛。它们确实钻进了你的心里。它们在我的脑海里，并且已经待了20年了。它们是蓝色的，不是吗？
Um, actually, they're green. And Mike realizes that later in the interview, and he wanted to make sure that I make it clear to you that he knows that they're green.
嗯，其实，它们是绿色的。迈克在采访后期意识到了这一点，他想确保我向你澄清，他知道它们是绿色的。
Check. If Aerith weren't as likeable, maybe if she weren't as pretty, if she didn't have those big green eyes, and she weren't as sweet, her death wouldn't have meant as much.
收到。如果爱丽丝没那么讨人喜欢，也许如果她没那么漂亮，如果她没有那双绿色的大眼睛，如果她没那么甜美，她的死亡就不会有那么大的意义了。
Would Aeris, the character, have been as effective if she were a little brother?
如果爱丽丝这个角色是个小弟弟，会同样有效吗？
Wow. That is a good question. I mean, I think she might have had to work harder as a little brother. Gosh, that's an awful thing to say. Yeah, I think he would have had to have a stronger personality. There would have been some more scenes of bonding with that character.
哇。这是一个好问题。我是说，我觉得作为小弟弟，她可能需要更努力才行。天哪，这话真糟糕。是的，我认为他必须拥有更强的个性。会有更多与那个角色建立联系的场景。
I mean, she has no personality.
我是说，她没有个性。
Yeah.
是啊。
There's a bird in the game that's called like a Chocobo, I think, that has more personality than Aeris does.
游戏里有一只鸟叫陆行鸟（Chocobo），我想，它的个性都比爱丽丝强。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, she's young and she's innocent. And I don't know. In the game, it's confusing whether or not she's like you, the protagonist's romantic interest, or like your little sister. And I think that that's intentional. Those are the things that it takes for you to feel protective of her. And then her death is the thing that energizes all of them to fight and win.
是的，她年轻而天真。我不知道。在游戏中，很难分辨她到底是像你，主角的恋爱对象，还是像你的小妹妹。我觉得那是故意的。这些就是让你对她产生保护欲所需要的。而她的死是激励所有人去战斗并获胜的事情。
It motivates the remaining party members. I think her death makes the stakes real. It's a game up until her death.
这激励了剩余的团队成员。我认为她的死让赌注变得真实。在她死之前，这只是个游戏。
Even after the Shinra drops the plate and crushes that entire city, you're like, wow. They mean business. But we've got a party of kickass heroes that's going to save the day. And then Aeris dies, and you're like, we might not save the day. It adds a layer of reality.
即使在神罗（Shinra）投下圆盘摧毁了整个城市之后，你也会想，哇。他们是认真的。但我们有一群厉害的英雄要拯救世界。然后爱丽丝死了，你会想，我们可能救不了世界。这增加了一层现实感。
And her death sends them to their actual mission-- to save the world. She's just a prop that gets them there. That's her whole function in the game.
她的死将他们引向了他们真正的使命——拯救世界。她只是一个把他们带到那里的道具。这就是她在游戏中的全部功能。
So basically, it's like she's this barely filled in character, and yet, just, that's enough to work, to make people have all these feelings and to actually cry when she dies.
所以基本上，她就像是一个几乎没被塑造丰满的角色，然而，这已经足够了，能起到作用，让人们产生所有这些感受，并在她死时真正哭泣。
All she needs is to seem vulnerable and nice.
她所需要的只是显得脆弱和善良。
This kind of story, the girl who needs rescuing, is still around. It's persistent. Despite all the films and stories that try to leave it behind, despite best efforts to quash it, you still run into it.
这种故事，需要被拯救的女孩，依然存在。它很顽固。尽管所有的电影和故事都试图抛弃它，尽管人们尽了最大努力去压制它，你还是会遇到它。
And you run into it in real life. People jump in, in real life to rescue young women and get so caught up in that heroic mission, that sometimes, like with Aeris, it kind of doesn't matter who the girl really is or if she wants to get rescued. She's sort of just a girl getting rescued. They don't see what the girl actually wants or needs. They don't see her. We have examples, real life examples. Stay with us.
而且你在现实生活中也会遇到它。人们在现实生活中冲进去拯救年轻女性，沉浸在那种英雄使命中，以至于有时，就像爱丽丝的情况一样，这个女孩到底是谁，或者她是否想被拯救，似乎并不重要。她只是一个正在被拯救的女孩。他们看不到这个女孩真正想要或需要什么。他们看不到她。我们有例子，现实生活中的例子。和我们在一起。
Act One, My New and Happy Birthday. So let's begin with a young woman that the United States government thought needed to be rescued, meaning well with good reason, at first anyway. Nadia Reiman explains.
第一幕，我的新快乐生日。所以让我们从一个美国政府认为需要被拯救的年轻女性开始，起初是出于善意。娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）解释说。
I'm looking at a sheet of paper with a couple photos of a young woman, a front view and a side view. Pretty small. She's got brown hair, brown eyes. But right below the photos is an X-ray of her jaw. The paper says the X-ray was ordered from O'Hare Airport in Chicago. And this X-ray is what sealed her fate.
我正看着一张纸，上面有这个年轻女性的几张照片，正面和侧面。很小。她有着棕色的头发，棕色的眼睛。但在照片的正下方是她下颚的X光片。纸上写着这张X光片是在芝加哥奥黑尔机场订购的。而这张X光片注定了她的命运。
Two years ago, the woman in the picture lands in Chicago. She's coming from Laos disoriented and jet lagged. Her name is Yong Xiong. She's meeting her fiancé, who's waiting for her with his mother and sister at the airport in Minneapolis. All she has to do is get through customs and make her connecting flight. So she steps up to the customs desk, all 4 feet 7 inches of her.
两年前，照片中的女人在芝加哥着陆。她从老挝过来，迷失方向且有时差。她的名字叫Yong Xiong。她在明尼阿波利斯的机场和她未婚夫及其母亲和姐姐见面。她所要做的就是通过海关，赶上转机航班。于是她走上海关柜台，她身高4英尺7英寸。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
They asked me how old I was. And I didn't know how to say it in English. So I showed them by fingers how old I was.
他们问我多大了。我不知道怎么用英语说。所以我用手指比划了我的年龄。
Can you show me? What did you do?
你能比划给我看吗？你是怎么做的？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I did this, and I did this.
我做了这个，又做了这个。
Yong holds up 10 fingers, pauses, then holds up nine more. 10 plus 9, 19. The Customs and Border Protection officer asked to see her passport. Yong doesn't speak English, and the officer doesn't speak her language, Hmong. There's no interpreter.
Yong举起10根手指，停顿了一下，又举起9根。10加9，19岁。海关和边境保护局的官员要求查看她的护照。Yong不会说英语，官员也不会说她的语言，苗语。没有翻译。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I gave them my passport, and then they looked at it and asked me to write down my birthday.
我把护照给了他们，他们看了看，让我写下我的生日。
What did you write down?
你写下了什么？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
6/4/1997.
6/4/1997。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
June 4, 1997. So then they asked me about my birthday again and again. After they got my birthday, they looked at me and kind of just thought whatever they're thinking, that maybe I was too little, or my size was something that they were looking at.
1997年6月4日。所以他们又一次问我生日。拿到生日后，他们看着我，想入非非，也许觉得我太小了，或者我的体型是他们关注的东西。
At this point, the officer pulls Yong aside and calls another officer, and another, and another. At least five Customs and Border Protection officers all inspect Yong and conclude that she, quote, appeared to be under the age of 18 based on her physical characteristics and childlike mannerisms. That's what it says in her immigration documents. I saw a bunch of them.
此时，官员把Yong拉到一边，叫来了另一名官员，接着又是另一名，又一名。至少有五名海关和边境保护局的官员检查了Yong，得出结论说，引用，“根据她的身体特征和孩子气的举止，看起来未满18岁。”移民文件中就是这么写的。我看了好几份。
Customs and Border Protection, or CBP, is trained to watch out for child trafficking. And they thought Yong looked too childlike to be 19. For what it's worth, Yong does look very young. When I met her, I thought so, too. She didn't look like a young woman. She looked 13.
海关和边境保护局（CBP）受过预防人口贩卖的培训。他们觉得Yong看起来太稚嫩，不像19岁。说实话，Yong看起来确实非常年轻。我见到她时，也这么想。她看起来不像一个年轻女性。她看起来像13岁。
So the officers went through her papers. They learned that she's here to get married. She has a fiancee visa, so to get it, she's already had to do an interview at the American embassy back in Laos. She's gone through a whole process to confirm that she wasn't lying, that her engagement wasn't a sham. And the government decided that yes, everything checked out. Visa approved.
所以官员们翻看了她的文件。他们得知她来这里是为了结婚。她有未婚夫签证，为了获得签证，她已经在老挝的美国大使馆进行过面试。她经历了整个流程，确认她没有撒谎，订婚不是伪造的。政府决定，是的，一切核实无误。签证获批。
But now, here she is, watching the officers going through her stuff, her bags, her suitcase. And they find pictures of her with her fiancé. I've seen them. Some are totally innocuous. They're from their engagement ceremony. Yong and her fiancé are both dressed up, tons of flowers.
但现在，她就在这里，看着官员检查她的东西、她的包、她的行李箱。他们发现了她和未婚夫的照片。我都看过。有些完全无害。那是他们订婚仪式上的照片。Yong和未婚夫都盛装打扮，到处是鲜花。
But in a couple pictures taken in some park, Yong's fiancé is kissing her on the mouth, and Yong is looking away. Her face is contorted. You could say she looks put off, disgusted even.
但在公园里拍的几张照片中，Yong的未婚夫在亲吻她的嘴，而Yong在看向别处。她的脸部扭曲。你可以说她看起来很不悦，甚至是厌恶。
Yong's family told me that Yong almost always looks grumpy in pictures. A cousin said that Yong never smiles, not even in the ones with just us girl cousins. But the officers note that in the photos with her fiancé, Yong seemed, quote, "physically scared and uncomfortable." They wonder whether Yong has been brought here against her will. Fiancé visas and work visas are a common way traffickers use to get people into the country legally.
Yong的家人告诉我，Yong在照片里几乎总是看起来脾气暴躁。一位堂姐妹说，Yong从来不笑，即使在只有我们堂姐妹的照片里也是如此。但官员们注意到，在和未婚夫的照片中，Yong似乎，引用，“身体上感到害怕和不舒服。”他们怀疑Yong是否违背自己的意愿被带到了这里。未婚夫签证和工作签证是人口贩子将人合法带入该国的常见方式。
So they get an officer who speaks Hmong and start to ask Yong a bunch of questions. What's your full name? Is this your passport? How many siblings do you have? Where did you meet your fiancé? Oh, and what was your age again? All of which Yong seemingly answers without hesitation. Yong Xiong. Yep, that's her passport. Seven sisters. Met her fiancé in Laos at a New Year's party. He's a US citizen, naturalized. He's also Hmong. Her date of birth? June 4, 1997. She's 19. He's 22.
所以他们找来一名会说苗语的官员，开始问Yong一堆问题。你的全名是什么？这是你的护照吗？你有几个兄弟姐妹？你在哪儿认识你未婚夫的？哦，你刚才说你多大来着？所有这些Yong似乎都毫不犹豫地回答了。Yong Xiong。没错，这是她的护照。七个姐妹。在老挝的新年聚会上认识了未婚夫。他是美国公民，已入籍。他也是苗族。她的出生日期？1997年6月4日。她19岁。他22岁。
So did they tell you at some point that they were worried that you were being trafficked?
所以他们有没有在某个时候告诉你，他们担心你被贩卖了？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
Yeah, they did tell me that.
是的，他们确实告诉了我。
What did you say when they told you that?
当他们那样告诉你时，你说了什么？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I just thought no, that's nuts. That's not what's happening.
我只是觉得不，这太疯狂了。那不是正在发生的事情。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I just told them it was my choice. That I was not being trafficked, and it was my decision to come to the US to be with my fiancé. Because it was my choice.
我告诉他们这是我的选择。我没有被贩卖，来美国和未婚夫在一起是我的决定。因为这是我的选择。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
The officers go through a checklist of 11 questions to determine whether Yong is being trafficked, stuff like, is she missing any documents? Does she appear scared? The answer to 10 of them is no. But then there's one about whether or not she's been coached on what to say. And that one the officers write down, quote, "Appear to be." That, plus the fact that she looked so young, seemed to make the officers believe that, yeah, she's probably trafficked.
官员们核对了一份包含11个问题的清单，以确定Yong是否被贩卖，比如，她是否丢失了文件？她看起来害怕吗？其中10个问题的答案是“不”。但有一个问题是关于她是否被教导过该说什么。关于那一个，官员写道，“看起来是”。那一点，加上她看起来那么年轻的事实，似乎让官员们相信，是的，她很可能是被贩卖的。
This checklist is just normal procedure. It's what officers have to do if they think something's going on. But then they did do something unusual. They wrote a new birthday into her file, January 1, 2000, making her a minor, 17 years old. There were a lot of unusual things that happened in Yong's case, and this made-up birthday is the first one.
这份清单只是正常程序。如果官员认为发生了什么事，他们必须这样做。但随后他们确实做了一件不寻常的事情。他们在她的档案里写了一个新的生日，2000年1月1日，使她成为一名未成年人，17岁。在Yong的案件中发生了很多不寻常的事情，这个虚构的生日是第一个。
The officers tell Yong she has to stay at the airport overnight. In the morning, they tell her through a Hmong speaker that they need to figure out if she's over 18. If she is, fine. If not, it'll be a problem. They tell Yong to find out how old you really are, we're going to take you to a dentist. Yong had never been to a dentist before. As she took a seat in the waiting room, she just thought, I guess this is normal. This is what they do when you enter the United States.
官员告诉Yong她必须在机场过夜。第二天早上，他们通过一名苗语翻译告诉她，他们需要弄清楚她是否超过18岁。如果是，没问题。如果不是，那会是个问题。他们告诉Yong，为了弄清楚你到底多大，我们要带你去见牙医。Yong以前从未见过牙医。当她在候诊室坐下时，她只是想，我想这是正常的。这是你进入美国时他们会做的事情。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I waited until they called my name, took me to the dental chair and told me to just sit down and lay back. And then they told me open my mouth. And then they had a stick that looked like it had a mirror on it. And they went to the side here and this side, all around on the inside.
我等着他们叫我的名字，把我带到牙科椅旁，让我坐下躺好。然后他们让我张开嘴。然后他们有一个看起来像末端带镜子的棒子。他们去了这边，然后那边，里面所有地方都看了一遍。
So did you know what was happening?
所以你知道发生了什么吗？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I didn't. It was just pointing and hand gestures. [SPEAKING HMONG] They said, open your mouth, like this.
我不知道。那只是指点和手势。[说苗语] 他们说，张开你的嘴，像这样。
Yong shows me how they moved their hand, like a sock puppet who just opened its mouth wide.
Yong向我演示了他们是如何移动手的，就像一个刚刚张开大嘴的袜偶。
Like with your hand?
就像用你的手？
[SPEAKING HMONG] Yes.
[说苗语] 是的。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I remember they told me to bite down, too.
我记得他们还让我咬合。
The dentist took the X-ray. No one would talk to me on the record about this, but because it's the government, there is a massive paper trail. And not just in Yong's case. I'm going to go deep on these tooth X-rays for a second, so bear with me. They're used all kinds of immigration cases, not just trafficking. And a lot rides on the results. If you're under 18, you have more protections. You get put into a shelter instead of a detention center. It's harder to get deported.
牙医拍了X光片。没有人会跟我记录在案地谈论这个，但因为这是政府行为，有大量的书面记录。不仅仅是在Yong的案子里。我要深入了解一下这些牙齿X光片，所以请耐心听我说。它们被用于各种移民案件，不仅仅是贩卖案件。而且结果关系重大。如果你未满18岁，你会有更多的保护。你会进入庇护所而不是拘留中心。遣返会更难。
But tooth X-rays are just not a very precise way to determine someone's age. The way it works is they measure how developed the roots of your molars are, and then based on that, the dentist can determine your age, but only within a range, usually around five years. So these X-rays can't tell you the difference between a 17-year-old and a 19-year-old. The same teeth might belong to a 15-year-old or a 20-year-old.
但牙齿X光片并不是确定某人年龄的精确方法。它是通过测量你臼齿牙根的发育程度来工作的，然后根据那个，牙医可以确定你的年龄，但只能在一个范围内，通常在五年左右。所以这些X光片无法告诉你17岁和19岁之间的区别。同样的牙齿可能属于一个15岁或20岁的人。
Back in 2007, Congress told ICE they were, quote, "troubled by the use of these exams," by their lack of accuracy and by the fact that migrants don't necessarily give consent. Congress said please stop. And yet, the government keeps using them anyway.
早在2007年，国会就告诉移民局（ICE），他们对“使用这些检查”感到不安，因为它们缺乏准确性，而且移民并不一定给予同意。国会说请停止。然而，政府还是继续使用它们。
And also, I found out the way the government is using these X-rays is alarming. They're using the teeth to make migrants the age they want them to be. A political science professor at Northwestern named Jackie Stevens is the one who told me about this. Back in 2018, Jackie was helping research a legal case. She runs something called the Deportation Research Clinic, which reports on government misconduct.
而且，我还发现政府使用这些X光片的方式令人震惊。他们利用牙齿使移民变成他们想要他们是的年龄。西北大学的一位政治学教授杰基·史蒂文斯（Jackie Stevens）告诉我这件事。2018年，杰基正在帮助研究一个法律案件。她经营着一个名为“遣返研究诊所”（Deportation Research Clinic）的机构，报告政府的不当行为。
And she got a giant document dump from the Office of Refugee Resettlement, ORR, people putting migrant kids into shelters. She got about 5,000 pages. The documents revealed that ORR had done hundreds of these forensic exams on migrants over the past couple of years.
她从难民安置办公室（ORR）得到了大量文件，这些人把移民儿童安置到庇护所。她得到了大约5000页文件。文件显示，ORR在过去几年里对移民进行了数百次这类法医检查。
Jackie found two things that ORR was doing wrong. One is they were using exams they weren't supposed to. The rule is that, legally speaking, if you're trying to prove someone is an adult, you can only take into account exams that show that with at least 75% probability. If they're below that threshold, you can't use them as evidence. But Jackie found that ORR was consistently determining people's ages with reports they weren't supposed to use.
杰基发现ORR做错了两件事。一是他们使用了不应该使用的检查。从法律上讲，如果你想证明某人是成年人，你只能参考那些能以至少75%的概率证明这一点的检查。如果低于那个门槛，你就不能把它们当作证据。但杰基发现，ORR一直在用他们不应该使用的报告来确定人们的年龄。
The second big thing Jackie found, time and again, ORR used the age range in the report to make the migrant 18 or over. So if they got a range that said this person could be 15 to 23, they'd pick at least 18. It's hard to know exactly why ORR would do this. I asked ORR why. Like, what's in it for them? They never responded.
杰基发现的第二件大事是，ORR反复利用报告中的年龄范围使移民年满18岁或以上。所以如果他们得到的范围显示这个人可能是15到23岁，他们就会选至少18岁。很难确切知道为什么ORR会这样做。我问过ORR原因。比如，这对他们有什么好处？他们从没回应。
But the way the teeth are usually being used is mostly to turn boys into men. In Yong's case, the opposite seemed to happen. Her X-ray was used to make her officially a child in the bureaucracy of the US immigration system. CBP had flagged her as a possible trafficking victim. She looked young. Southeast Asia is a trafficking hotbed.
但牙齿通常被利用的方式主要是把男孩变成男人。在Yong的案例中，似乎发生了相反的情况。她的X光片被用来使她在美式移民官僚体系中正式成为一名儿童。CBP已经将她标记为可能的贩卖受害者。她看起来很年轻。东南亚是人口贩卖的温床。
And once that idea took hold of US government agencies, it was very hard for Yong to shake. Because the way I see it, if the government sees Yong as a girl entering the country in danger, as a girl coerced, a girl too small to be a bride, then they had to protect her. And even if part of the officer suspected she might be telling the truth, that she might really be 19, that she might really be here because she wants to get married, they'd have to be sure-- like 100% sure. So they had her teeth X-rayed.
一旦这个想法在美国政府机构中扎根，Yong就很难摆脱它。因为在我看来，如果政府把Yong看作是一个身处险境进入该国的女孩，一个被强迫的女孩，一个太小而不能作为新娘的女孩，那么他们就必须保护她。即使部分官员怀疑她可能说的是真的，她可能真的19岁，她可能真的因为想结婚而来到这里，他们也必须确保——比如100%确定。所以他们拍了她的牙齿X光片。
In the documents, the dentist writes, quote, "The range of possible ages is 14.76 to 19.56 years." In other words, it's totally plausible that Yong could be 19 as she's been saying. But she could also be 17, like the officers decided. They seemed to use the X-rays as proof that they're right. Yong's new birth date of January 1, 2000, it sticks. And it starts to reshape her life.
在文件中，牙医写道，引用，“可能的年龄范围是14.76到19.56岁。”换句话说，Yong可能是她说的那样19岁是完全合理的。但她也可能是17岁，正如官员们所决定的那样。他们似乎把X光片当作他们正确的证据。Yong新的出生日期2000年1月1日，就这样定下了。它开始重塑她的生活。
The agents drive Yong straight from the dentist to a juvenile shelter. It's in Chicago. It looks like a school. It's run by ORR. She's told she can't talk to her fiancé, the supposed trafficker. As soon as she is allowed to, Yong calls her mom.
特工把Yong从牙医那儿直接开车带到了一个青少年庇护所。它在芝加哥。看起来像所学校。由ORR管理。她被告知不能和她的未婚夫通话，那个所谓的贩卖者。一旦被允许，Yong就给妈妈打了电话。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I just told her they brought me to this place to stay with all these kids. I just thought, now I'm in their hands, and this is where they put me. I don't know what's going to happen next.
我只是告诉她，他们带我到这个地方和所有这些孩子待在一起。我只是想，现在我在他们手里了，这就是他们把我放的地方。我不知道接下来会发生什么。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
Yong is assigned to a room with four other girls. There are 13-year-olds at the shelter, but also babies. She spends her days doing all these kids things, like she has to vote for which kids movie to watch during movie night. She goes on trips to the zoo. She does math worksheets. She gets clothes to wear while she's there, but they don't fit her because she's so small. At first, Yong soldiers on. She starts to learn English. She thinks she'll just sit tight, and it'll all get sorted out. She's pragmatic, keeps a tight lid on her emotions.
Yong被分配到一个有四个女孩的房间。庇护所里有13岁的孩子，也有婴儿。她每天做所有这些孩子做的事情，比如她必须投票选出电影之夜看什么儿童电影。她去动物园旅行。她做数学练习册。她在那里时会领到衣服穿，但因为她太小，衣服不合身。起初，Yong硬撑着。她开始学英语。她想她会静观其变，一切都会解决的。她很务实，严格控制着自己的情绪。
When she's assigned to a clinician, Yong tells her right away, like the day they meet, that she's 19. She's here to be with her fiancé. Two days later, she brings it up again. Nothing changes. She brings it up dozens of times. It's in all her shelter documents. In one note, the clinician writes, quote, "Minor repeated to clinician she is not under 18. Clinician told minor she believes her. But there needs to be documentation to prove her statement."
当她被分配给一名临床医生时，Yong在见面的第一天就直说她19岁了。她是来找未婚夫的。两天后，她又提到了这件事。什么都没改变。她提了几十次。这记录在案的所有庇护所文件中。在一份笔记中，临床医生写道，引用，“未成年人反复向临床医生重申她未满18岁。临床医生告诉未成年人她相信她。但需要有文件来证明她的说法。”
Day in and day out, Yong keeps asking, what's happening? Why am I here? Her frustration starts to bubble.
日复一日，Yong不断询问，到底发生了什么？我为什么在这里？她的沮丧开始显露。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I told them I'm almost 20. I came here in April, and my birthday's in June. So I'm almost 20. They told me, we can't change that for you. We can't help you with that because this birthday that is on the paperwork is what came with you when you were admitted into this building.
我告诉他们我快20岁了。我是四月份来到这里的，我生日在六月。所以我快20岁了。他们告诉我，我们不能为你改变这一点。我们不能帮你，因为你被接纳进入这栋大楼时所附的文件上写的那个生日就是你的生日。
This is not true, by the way. ORR makes changes to ages based on dental X-rays like the ones I mentioned at any point. They can happen even after someone's been admitted. Yong has an aunt named Xia in Minnesota, one she doesn't know very well. They met once back in Laos.
顺便说一下，这不是真的。ORR随时都可以根据我提到的那种牙齿X光片修改年龄。即使在某人被接纳后也会发生。Yong在明尼苏达州有一位阿姨叫Xia，她不太熟悉。她们在老挝见过一次。
And she asks, since they won't release her to be with her fiancé, can she be released to go live with her aunt? The shelter contacts the aunt to test her DNA to make sure she and Yong are related. They are. But the shelter decides not to release Yong to Aunt Xia because Xia tells them that Yong is an adult. So the shelter concludes she might let Yong run off with the fiancé/supposed trafficker.
她问，既然他们不释放她去和未婚夫在一起，她能被释放去和阿姨住吗？庇护所联系了阿姨进行DNA测试，以确保她和Yong有亲属关系。她们确实有。但庇护所决定不把Yong释放给Xia阿姨，因为Xia告诉他们Yong是成年人。所以庇护所认为她可能会让Yong和未婚夫/所谓的贩卖者跑掉。
At one point, her documents say, quote, "Minor began to state she doesn't know what to do anymore. And she cannot think of any solutions and feels stuck in the program." And also, quote, "Minor states that she is 20 years old, and no one believes her."
在某个时候，她的文件上写着，引用，“未成年人开始陈述她不知道该怎么办了。她想不出任何解决方案，感觉被困在项目中。”还有，引用，“未成年人陈述她20岁了，没人相信她。”
January 1, 2018 was looming closer. At that point, Yong would reach her fake 18th birthday, after which she'd be a legal adult, again, and not really shelter material.
2018年1月1日临近。到那时，Yong将达到她虚构的18岁生日，在那之后，她将再次成为合法成年人，不再是庇护所的对象。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
So as I stayed there and it got closer to my 18th birthday, the 18th birthday that they gave me, they had informed me that once I had turned 18, they were going to take me out and put me in a different facility. And so that's when they switched it and gave me a new birthday, September 1, 2002.
所以当我待在那里，快到我18岁生日时，那个他们给我的18岁生日，他们通知我，一旦我满18岁，他们要把我带走，把我放进另一个设施。所以就在那时，他们转换了它，给了我一个新的生日，2002年9月1日。
Wait, so they switched you and gave you another fake birthday?
等等，所以他们把你转换了，给了你另一个虚构的生日？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
So they gave me a new fake birthday, but one that made me younger, too.
所以他们给了我一个新的虚构生日，但那个生日也把我变小了。
Did you ask why?
你问过原因吗？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I did. And I asked them, why couldn't they just give me my real birthday? And they said, no, they couldn't do that. And they didn't know why they couldn't do that.
问过。我问他们，为什么不能只给我我的真实生日？他们说，不，他们做不到。他们也不知道为什么做不到。
I looked into it. It turns out ORR resubmitted the X-rays of Yong's teeth to a second dentist who concluded Yong could be anywhere between 15 and 20 years old. After which, ORR did change her birth date. But they used the lowest end of the range possible. The documents say DHS, the agency that oversees everything related to immigration, told them to. Her new, new birth date is now September 1, 2002.
我调查了一下。结果发现ORR将Yong的牙齿X光片重新提交给了第二位牙医，他得出结论Yong的年龄可能在15到20岁之间。在那之后，ORR确实更改了她的出生日期。但他们使用了可能范围内的最低端。文件说，国土安全部（DHS），即监督移民相关一切事务的机构，告诉他们要这么做。她新的新出生日期现在是2002年9月1日。
The shelter orders a wrist X-ray to assess the age of Yong's skeleton. The results come back that Yong is likely 18. The doctor concludes that Yong is still 15, just has, quote, "advanced bone age." She's gone from being 19 to 17 to 15, just like Benjamin Button.
庇护所命令拍一张手腕X光片以评估Yong骨骼的年龄。结果显示Yong很可能是18岁。医生得出结论，Yong仍然只有15岁，只是，引用，“骨龄提前”。她从19岁变成17岁再变成15岁，就像本杰明·巴顿（Benjamin Button）一样。
You know that kind of nightmare where you're trying to run, but you can't move? Yong says living inside the shelter was just like that. Day after day, she watches the kids around her leave to go stay with relatives. But she's trapped. The clinician notes that Yong's become more irritated. And then about 10 months into her shelter stay, something pushes Yong over the edge.
你知道那种想跑却动不了的噩梦吗？Yong说住在庇护所里就像那样。一天又一天，她看着身边的孩子离开去和亲戚住在一起。但她被困住了。临床医生注意到Yong变得更加烦躁了。然后在大约10个月的庇护所生活后，某件事让Yong崩溃了。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
I was hanging out with my friends, and then my friends had asked me what my name was. I told them my name was Yong Xiong. And so the friend came and said, well, who is Jane Doe? And I told them, huh? I don't know who Jane Doe is. The friend said come here. I wasn't able to read and write well enough yet. And so the friend said, let me show you.
我和朋友待在一起时，朋友问我叫什么名字。我告诉她们我叫Yong Xiong。所以那个朋友走过来说，好吧，简·多（Jane Doe）是谁？我告诉她们，啊？我不知道简·多是谁。朋友说过来。我当时读写能力还不够好。所以朋友说，让我展示给你看。
On the outside of my door, it said Jane Doe as my name. I was so angry. And I had a permanent marker with me, so I went outside of my room and blacked out the Jane Doe name that was on the outside of my door. And I just marked it all off. A worker came by and said, who vandalized my name on my door? And I told her, I did it, because that's not my name.
我门外面写着简·多作为我的名字。我太生气了。我随身带着记号笔，所以我走到房间外面，涂黑了门外写的简·多的名字。我把全涂掉了。一个工作人员走过来说，谁毁坏了我门上的名字？我告诉她，我做的，因为那不是我的名字。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
Yong had had it.
Yong受够了。
And then what did you do after that?
那之后你做了什么？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
Then after that, I refused to pick up my meals under the name Jane Doe. And they were asking why I wouldn't pick up my meals. And I said because I don't know who Jane Doe is. I'm not Jane Doe. At that moment, I was really angry, thinking I have a mom. I have a dad who gave me my name. Why not use my real name? Why give me that name? I didn't like that name at all.
然后在那之后，我拒绝以简·多的名义去领饭。他们问我为什么不去领饭。我说因为我不知道简·多是谁。我不是简·多。在那一刻，我真的非常生气，想到我有妈妈。我有给了我名字的爸爸。为什么不用我的真名？为什么要给我那个名字？我一点也不喜欢那个名字。
So the shelter is like, fine. We won't call you Jane Doe anymore. For the first time in almost a year, Yong is heard.
所以庇护所说，好吧。我们不再叫你简·多了。将近一年来第一次，Yong被听到了。
Meanwhile, in the outside world, many parts of the US government with many different acronyms are trying to figure out what the hell is going on with Yong. ORR, the shelter people, who've been given the new age by DHS, the immigration people, are running around with the OS, the State Department people, to confirm what CBP, the Border Protection people, originally thought of Yong, the migrant person.
与此同时，在外界，许多拥有不同缩写的美国政府部门正试图弄清楚Yong身上到底发生了什么。ORR，那些庇护所的人，被国土安全部（DHS，移民机构）告知了新年龄，正忙着与国务院（OS）的人确认CBP（边境保护部门）最初对Yong（这位移民）的看法。
It turns out, according to Yong's family, someone from the US embassy office in Laos went around Yong's village asking questions, asking to see her family registry, which is this record that families in Laos keep that basically lists who was born when. Also, they asked the Laos embassy to confirm Yong's fifth grade and ninth grade school certificates. Both have her age, and the embassy says they're both legit
结果发现，据Yong的家人说，美国驻老挝大使馆的人员去过Yong的村庄问问题，要求查看她的家庭登记册，即老挝家庭保留的记录，基本上列出了谁在何时出生。此外，他们要求老挝大使馆确认Yong的五年级和九年级学校证书。两份证书上都有她的年龄，大使馆说它们都是合法的。
I talked to an ICE spokesperson, more immigration people, and they say that going deep like that doesn't sound uncommon. Like if they think they have a case of human trafficking on their hands, they spend time and resources checking it out, especially if they think the victim is a minor and especially if the region is known as a place where trafficking is common, which Southeast Asia is.
我采访了一位移民局（ICE）的发言人，更多移民部门的人，他们说像这样深入调查听起来并不罕见。比如，如果他们认为他们手中有人口贩卖案件，他们会花时间和资源调查，特别是如果他们认为受害者是未成年人，特别是如果该地区是众所周知的贩卖常见地（东南亚就是这样）。
In the embassy's report about Yong, it says that, quote, "It does occur that the Hmong population will represent themselves as older for the purpose of applying for a visa." And quote, "Usually under questioning, the girls will admit their real age if they lied." And quote, "Common for them to look very young, malnutritioned, underdeveloped."
在大使馆关于Yong的报告中，它说，引用，“苗族人口为了申请签证而虚报年龄的情况确实发生。”并且引用，“通常在盘问下，如果女孩撒谎，她们会承认真实年龄。”以及引用，“她们看起来非常年轻、营养不良、发育不全是很常见的。”
In Laos, the average height of a woman is about 4 foot 9 inches. This makes them one of the shortest populations in the world. At 4 foot 7, Yong is shorter than average, but not unusual for Laos. It's obvious that Yong is being measured with a Western ruler.
在老挝，女性的平均身高约为4英尺9英寸。这使她们成为世界上身材最矮小的人群之一。Yong身高4英尺7英寸，比平均水平矮，但这在老挝并不罕见。显而易见，Yong正被用西方标尺来衡量。
The fiancé was never charged with anything. He says no law enforcement came to talk to him. Lawyers that deal with cases like this told me this is unusual if he was actually a trafficking suspect. Normally, an investigator from ICE would show up to interview him, but as far as I can tell, no one did. There is one thing I found out, though-- something about Yong's fiancé that troubled me when I heard it.
未婚夫从未被指控任何罪名。他说没有执法人员来找他谈话。处理此类案件的律师告诉我，如果他真的是贩卖嫌疑人，这是不寻常的。通常，移民局的调查员会出面面试他，但据我所知，没人这么做。不过，我确实发现了一件事——关于Yong未婚夫的一件事，当我听到它时，让我很不安。
One person working with Yong told me that he was kind of a big jerk, that he yelled and threatened the shelter when he was talking to them about Yong, and that when the shelter said this will be a process to get her out, he said fine. If you don't let her out, then I don't want her anyway. The person I spoke with said that's why the shelter didn't want to release her to him. They were afraid he didn't really care about her.
一个和Yong一起工作的人告诉我，他有点像个大混蛋，他在和庇护所谈论Yong时大喊大叫并威胁过他们，当庇护所说让她出来需要一个流程时，他说好吧。如果你不让她出来，那我就不要她了。我和那个人谈话时他说这就是庇护所不想把她交给他的原因。他们担心他并不真正关心她。
I ran this by Yong's fiancé, and he says none of this is true. He would have loved to talk to Yong, but he says the shelter wouldn't let him. He says that at one point, he took a week off and weighted by the phone because the shelter said they would call him. They never did.
我把这件事告诉了Yong的未婚夫，他说这些都不是真的。他很想和Yong通话，但他说庇护所不让他。他说有一次，他请了一周假，守在电话旁，因为庇护所说会给他打电话。他们从没打过。
Finally, on June 8, 2018, about 14 months after entering the shelter and four days after her 21st birthday, Yong is released. They release her as a minor under the custody of her aunt, Aunt Xia. This is her.
终于，2018年6月8日，在她进入庇护所大约14个月后，在她21岁生日后四天，Yong被释放了。他们以未成年人的身份将她释放到Xia阿姨的监护下。这是她。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
They said, we are releasing her to you. You need to be aware that she is only 15. We've given her multiple birth dates, but that's the birthday that she's coming home with. It is the birthday that she is 15 years old. You need to keep an eye on her. You must know that anyone who is 18 or older comes and takes her to go get married, you will go to jail for it.
他们说，我们正在把她交给你。你需要知道她只有15岁。我们给了她多个出生日期，但那是她回家时所持有的生日。那是她15岁时的生日。你需要看好她。你必须知道，任何18岁或以上的人来带她去结婚，你都会因此坐牢。
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
What did you think about that?
你怎么想的？
[SPEAKING HMONG]
[说苗语]
So I didn't say much, and I didn't think much. I just thought, OK, the Lord gave her a birthday. But you choose to give her a birthday, and just send her home with the birthday you gave her. Even if she's just 10, I just want her home.
所以我没说什么，也没多想。我只是想，好吧，上帝给了她一个生日。但你们选择给她一个生日，就这样让她带着你们给的生日回家。即使她只有10岁，我只想她回家。
So Yong went to live with her Aunt Xia in St. Paul, 15 miles from her fiancé. In May, I visited them. Yong's been living with Xia for a year. She has to, because according to one part of the government, she's 17, which means--
所以Yong去圣保罗和Xia阿姨住在一起，离她未婚夫15英里。五月，我去看了她们。Yong和Xia住了一年了。她必须住，因为根据政府的一部分，她17岁，这意味着——
OK. So the first thing that I want to do is we finished female reproductive system, right? We've finished male reproductive system with the parts, right?
好的。所以我想做的第一件事是，我们完成了女性生殖系统，对吧？我们完成了男性生殖系统的各个部分，对吧？
She has to go to high school. It's one of the conditions of her release. I went with her on a Monday to her health class, where she was learning about pregnancy and the placenta. She's a freshman there. And you know what? She likes high school. She's there with a bunch of English language learners. So the teacher helps the students repeat everything.
她必须去上高中。这是她获释的条件之一。周一我和她一起去了她的健康课，她在学习怀孕和胎盘的知识。她是那里的一年级新生。你知道吗？她喜欢高中。她和一群英语学习者在一起。所以老师帮助学生重复一切。
Can you say it with me, everybody?
大家能和我一起说吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Passes into the--
进入到——
--cord--
——脐带——
--to the mother--
——给母亲——
--to the mother, then--
——给母亲，然后——
--then out. Yeah. So the mother, she gets the waste, and she has to say, oh! Bathroom.
——然后出去。是的。所以母亲，她得到废物，她必须说，哦！卫生间。
She's in a school full of other immigrant kids. Most of them don't know how much older she is. She doesn't bring it up, and they don't seem aware of it. And then finally, after more than two years of waiting, Yong got her identity back. She had an immigration hearing just two weeks ago at the end of June, a little after her 22nd birthday.
她在一所全是其他移民孩子的学校里。他们大多数人不知道她大多少。她没提，他们似乎也不知道。然后终于，在等待了两年多后，Yong找回了她的身份。两周前，也就是六月底，在她22岁生日后不久，她举行了一次移民听证会。
DHS told Yong's lawyers that they were dropping the age thing. They said they were not contesting her passport or, quote, "any of its contents," which of course include her birth date-- you know, the one she says is real, June 4, 1997.
国土安全部告诉Yong的律师，他们放弃了年龄问题。他们说他们不反对她的护照或，引用，“它的任何内容”，当然这包括她的出生日期——你知道，那个她说真实的，1997年6月4日。
Yong went home that day and called her fiancé at night. It was the first time they were allowed to talk since she got to the States. They cried. Then they made dinner plans. Yong was happy, but sort of isn't used to the idea that this is real. Same thing for her fiancé. He says he keeps wondering if she really is here for good and if legally, he really is allowed to marry her. So for now, he just waits for Yong to call him and make plans.
Yong那天回家，晚上给未婚夫打了电话。这是她来到美国后第一次被允许通话。他们哭了。然后他们制定了晚餐计划。Yong很开心，但对这一切是真实的还有点不适应。她的未婚夫也一样。他说他一直在想她是否真的永远留下来了，法律上是否真的允许他娶她。所以现在，他只是等待Yong打给他并制定计划。
So I still can't say exactly why any of this happened to Yong. I reached out to all the immigration agencies involved in this case. CBP and ICE both declined to comment on Yong, and ORR as well, because, they say, she's a minor. Her lawyers' take on why this happened is they think the government made a judgment call and screwed up, and just started something in motion they didn't know how to stop.
所以我仍然无法确切说明为什么Yong身上会发生这一切。我联系了此案涉及的所有移民机构。海关和边境保护局（CBP）和移民局（ICE）都拒绝评论Yong的情况，ORR也是，因为，他们说，她是未成年人。她律师对发生此事的看法是，他们认为政府做出了判断并搞砸了，只是启动了一些他们不知道如何停止的事情。
On some level, it seems like maybe everyone was just afraid to miss a trafficking case. And then her passport, her visa, all her documents from Laos just didn't matter anymore. Yong's still here under a fiancé visa, so she has to get married. If she doesn't, she has to go back to Laos. She's back at square one. It's like she just came into the States, holding her passport and her suitcase. Like no time has passed when she landed at O'Hare in 2017-- except it has.
在某种程度上，似乎也许每个人都只是害怕错过人口贩卖案件。然后她的护照、她的签证、所有她从老挝带来的文件就不再重要了。Yong依然持未婚夫签证待在这里，所以她必须结婚。如果她不结婚，她就得回老挝。她又回到了原点。就像她刚刚来到美国，手里拿着护照和行李箱一样。就像2017年在奥黑尔着陆时没有任何时间流逝一样——除了时间确实流逝了。
Nadia Reiman is one of the producers of our show.
娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - YOUTH GROUP, "FOREVER YOUNG"]
[音乐 - 青年组，“永远年轻”]
Coming up, a whole country gets obsessed with rescuing a girl-- a missing girl. This in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，整个国家都沉迷于拯救一个女孩——一个失踪的女孩。一分钟后来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Save the Girl, real life damsel-in-distress stories, where rescuers charge in, going full force on the rescuing, assuming that they know what is best for the girl that they're saving-- but really, not paying too much attention to what she might like or who she really is.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目，“拯救女孩”，现实生活中的落难少女故事，救援人员冲进去，全力以赴地营救，假设他们知道什么对他们拯救的女孩最好——但实际上，并没有太关注她可能喜欢什么或者她到底是谁。
This kind of saving the innocent girl, damsel-in-distress story, there's this old video that I love of the novelist Kurt Vonnegut, and he's talking about the effect of that story on people. In the video, he's standing at a blackboard, explaining that classic stories each have their own formula. And then he's literally mapping them out on the board.
这种拯救无辜女孩、落难少女的故事，我喜欢库尔特·冯内古特（Kurt Vonnegut）的一段老视频，他正在谈论这个故事对人们的影响。视频中，他站在黑板前，解释经典故事各自有自己的公式。然后他实际上把它们画在黑板上。
So there's no reason why the simple shapes of stories can't be fed into computers. They are beautiful shapes.
所以没有理由说简单的故事结构不能输入计算机。它们是美丽的形状。
And then he starts to draw graphs, draw these shapes representing different types of stories. So picture, OK, like in school, an x and a y-axis, right? With me? And then the vertical axis represents here how good or how badly a person is doing in their life. So bad fortune at the bottom of the line, good fortune at the top.
然后他开始画图表，画出这些代表不同类型故事的形状。所以想象一下，好吧，就像在学校里，x轴和y轴，对吧？跟我来？然后垂直轴代表一个人生活中过得好坏。底部是坏运气，顶部是好运气。
Sickness and poverty down here, wealth and then boisterous good health up there. Now this is the BE axis.
疾病和贫穷在下面，财富和充沛的健康在上面。这就是BE轴。
BE axis, that is the horizontal line that stretches from the left side of the chalkboard to the right side of the chalkboard. B is the beginning of the story. E is the ending. And then Vonnegut demonstrates how this works. He says that some stories start with the person who's kind of happy, so they begin more than halfway up that vertical line that measures good or bad fortune.
BE轴，那是从黑板左侧延伸到黑板右侧的水平线。B是故事的开始。E是结局。然后冯内古特展示了这是如何工作的。他说有些故事始于过得还算快乐的人，所以他们从衡量好运或霉运的垂直线的一半以上开始。
So I would start a little above average. Why get a depressing person? We'll start-- The whole thing, we call this story man in hole. But it needn't be about a man, and it needn't be about somebody getting into a hole. But it's just a good way to remember it. Somebody gets into trouble, gets out of it again.
所以我开始会比平均水平高一点。为什么要找一个令人沮丧的人？我们开始——这一切，我们称这个故事为“人在洞里”。但这不需要是关于一个男人，也不需要是关于某人掉进一个洞里。但这只是记住它的好方法。某人遇到麻烦，然后又脱身。
He's drawing a curve, like a sine wave. And it dips down into bad fortune when he says somebody gets into trouble and then comes back up again for gets out of it.
他画了一条曲线，像正弦波。当他说某人遇到麻烦时，它向下陷入霉运，然后为了“脱身”又向上升。
People love that story. They never get sick of it.
人们喜欢那个故事。他们永远不会厌倦它。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
All right.
好了。
All right. So Vonnegut's done, man in hole. He then does boy gets girl and draws a diagram for that kind of rom-commy story. And then he tells the audience he's going to clue them in on the most powerful kind of story of all. This kind of story starts, he says, with the main character not doing well at all. Like the curve starts near the bottom of the good fortune and bad fortune vertical line.
好了。所以冯内古特的“人在洞里”讲完了。他接着讲“男孩遇见女孩”，并为那种浪漫喜剧故事画了一个图表。然后他告诉观众他要透露所有故事中最强大的类型。这种故事开始于，他说，主角过得一点都不好。就像曲线开始于好运和霉运垂直线的底部附近。
But we're going to start way down here. Who is so low? It's a little girl. What's happened? Her mother has died.
但我们要从这里开始。谁这么惨？是一个小女孩。发生了什么？她的母亲去世了。
Her father has remarried a vile-tempered, ugly woman with two nasty daughters, big daughters. You've heard it. See?
她的父亲娶了一个性格恶劣、丑陋的女人，带着两个讨厌的女儿，大女儿。你们听过。看到没？
Anyway, there's a party at the palace that night. She can't go. She has to help everybody else get ready. She has to stay home. OK, so the fairy godmother comes. Gives her shoes, gives her a stocking, give her mascara.
不管怎样，那天晚上宫殿里有个聚会。她不能去。她必须帮其他人准备。她必须待在家里。好吧，神仙教母来了。给她鞋子，给她袜子，给她睫毛膏。
They're laughing because with each item, he gives the curve a big bump up, like a series of stairs heading upwards.
他们大笑，因为每给一件东西，他就让曲线向上弹跳一大下，就像一系列向上的台阶。
Gives her a means of transportation. Goes to the party, dances with the prince, has a swell time.
给了她交通工具。去聚会，和王子跳舞，玩得很开心。
Now we're way high up on the graph.
现在我们在图表的很高处。
Boing, boing, boing, boing.
砰，砰，砰，砰。
With the boings of the grandfather clock striking, he draws a vertical line going straight back down towards misery, though not quite as low as she was at the start.
随着祖父钟敲响的声音，他画了一条垂直线直接回落向苦难，虽然没有她开始时那么低。
Does she wind up at the same level? Of course not. She will remember that dance for the rest of her life. Now, she poops along on this level till the prince comes, and shoe fits.
她最终回到同样的水平吗？当然不。她余生都会记得那场舞。现在，她在这一层上混日子，直到王子出现，鞋子合脚。
He draws the curve upward until it hits the very top of the blackboard, as high as he can go, and writes an infinity sign.
他把曲线向上画，直到它到达黑板的最顶端，画得尽可能高，并写了一个无穷大符号。
She achieves offscale happiness. It so happens that this is the most popular story in our civilization, Western civilization, as we love to hear this story. Every time it's retold, somebody makes another million dollars. You're welcome to do it.
她获得了无法衡量的幸福。碰巧这是我们文明，西方文明中最受欢迎的故事，因为我们喜欢听这个故事。每一次重述，都有人再赚一百万美元。欢迎你这样做。
Which, really, all of that is the perfect introduction to our next act, Act Two, Frida Be You and Me. When an entire country becomes obsessed with a version of this story, it becomes obsessed with rescuing a girl, like the prince rescued Cinderella, until that venerable old pot took a weird twist. Aviva DeKornfeld explains what happened.
这实际上是我们的下一幕，“弗里达，你和我”的完美介绍。当整个国家都沉迷于这个故事的一个版本时，它变得沉迷于拯救一个女孩，就像王子拯救灰姑娘一样，直到那个古老的大罐子发生了一个奇怪的转折。阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）解释了发生了什么。
Every year on September 19, Mexico runs through an earthquake drill. And on September 19 in 2017, the whole country ran through the drill as usual at 11:00 AM. Roughly two hours later, a real earthquake hit. It was a big one, an estimated magnitude of 7.1. Over 300 people died. Thousands of buildings were damaged. And one of those buildings was a school in southern Mexico City.
每年9月19日，墨西哥都会进行地震演习。2017年9月19日，全国照常在上午11点进行了演习。大约两个小时后，真正的地震发生了。这是一场大地震，估计震级为7.1。超过300人死亡。数千座建筑受损。其中一座建筑是墨西哥城南部的一所学校。
When the school fell, it wasn't a total collapse. Only one side fully crumbled. There was a big hole in one of the walls. And through it, one of the classrooms was visible-- posters, and kids' drawings, and big colored letters in the midst of destruction. 19 kids were killed at the school, and a bunch more were injured. So pretty quickly, tons of media showed up. And the school became crowded with people trying to help.
当学校倒塌时，并没有完全坍塌。只有一边完全崩塌。其中一堵墙上有一个大洞。透过它，其中一间教室清晰可见——海报、孩子们的画，和破坏中的大彩色字母。19名孩子在学校里丧生，更多人受伤。所以很快，大量媒体出现了。学校变得挤满了试图帮忙的人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
We started digging, and digging was really not easy.
我们开始挖掘，挖掘确实不容易。
This is Felipe Duran Emiliano. He's a member of the Topo Azteca, which is a volunteer rescue brigade. Felipe and the other Topos find a tiny gap in the collapsed part of the school about a foot wide. They worked to open it up, and soon they find the body of a teacher. Felipe said she had her arms stretched out open, as if she'd been trying to protect others. The Topos lift the teacher's body out and place her on a stretcher. Then they keep hammering the concrete, looking for other victims.
这是费利佩·杜兰·埃米利亚诺（Felipe Duran Emiliano）。他是“Topo Azteca”的成员，这是一支志愿者救援队。费利佩和其他Topo在学校倒塌的部分发现了一个大约一英尺宽的小缝隙。他们努力把它撬开，很快他们发现了老师的遗体。费利佩说她双臂伸开，好像在试图保护别人。Topo抬出老师的遗体并放在担架上。然后他们继续锤打混凝土，寻找其他受害者。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And once I remove this piece of concrete, I noticed two small feet.
一旦我移开这块混凝土，我注意到两只小脚。
The feet belonged to a little boy. They find three more kids. The other volunteers want to pull the bodies out as quickly as possible, keep looking for other people. But Felipe paused.
脚属于一个小男孩。他们又发现了三个孩子。其他志愿者想尽快把尸体拉出来，继续寻找其他人。但费利佩停顿了一下。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And so what I said to my co-worker, Machete, can you please ask them to wait?
所以我对我的同事马切特（Machete）说，你能请他们等一下吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Because I want to say a prayer for this small child and also for the other children that have already been taken out.
因为我想为这个小孩以及其他已经被带出来的孩子祈祷。
They keep going, though the chances of finding survivors is shrinking. As time passes, the rescue mission becomes less heroic and more tedious. And then on Wednesday morning, there's news. The TV news program interviews Navy Admiral Jose Luis Vergara, who's on site. The Navy's overseeing the rescue.
他们继续前进，尽管找到幸存者的几率正在缩小。随着时间的推移，救援任务变得不再那么英雄，而是更加枯燥。然后在周三早上，有消息了。电视新闻节目采访了在现场的安保部长，海军上将何塞·路易斯·维尔加拉（Jose Luis Vergara）。海军正在监督救援工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He says we have indication of a girl who is alive. Rescuers have used a thermal scanner and a motion sensor, and they've detected what seems to be a person moving.
他说我们有迹象显示一个女孩还活着。救援人员使用了热成像扫描仪和运动传感器，他们探测到了似乎是一个人移动的迹象。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
One of the rescuers says they can see her moving her fingers. News of this girl trapped alive quickly becomes the biggest story of the earthquake. The first reporter led into the cordoned off area around the school is this woman named Danielle Dithurbide. She works for Televisa, the largest Spanish language broadcaster in the world. She's dressed like she's going into battle, khaki vest and a hardhat that looks like a helmet.
其中一名救援人员说他们能看到她移动手指。这个被困女孩活着的报道很快成为地震最大的新闻。第一个被允许进入学校周围警戒区的记者是这位名叫丹妮尔·迪图尔比德（Danielle Dithurbide）的女士。她为全球最大的西班牙语广播公司 Televisa 工作。她穿着好像要上战场，卡其色背心和看起来像头盔的安全帽。
And anytime there's new information, Danielle hears about it. She's giving constant updates. The girl seems to be trapped underneath a table.
而且每当有新信息，丹妮尔都会听到。她一直在提供最新消息。女孩似乎被困在桌子底下。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
We don't want to break it because it could collapse, Danielle says. So the rescue workers figure out how to insert supports around the wreckage. The Navy threads a hose through a crack in the rubble to try to get water to the little girl.
我们不想打破它，因为它可能会坍塌，丹妮尔说。所以救援人员想出如何插入支撑物围绕残骸。海军穿过废墟中的缝隙插入一根软管，试图给小女孩送水。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
This is another Navy official, undersecretary Angel Enrique Sarmiento. He says they've been giving the little girl water through the hose. The rescue workers try to contact the person. They say, tap twice if you can hear us. But there are so many people around the school, it's way too loud for them to hear her.
这是另一位海军官员，副部长安赫尔·恩里克·萨米恩托（Angel Enrique Sarmiento）。他说他们一直通过软管给小女孩水。救援人员试图联系那个人。他们说，如果你能听到我们，敲两下。但学校周围有太多人，对他们来说太吵了，听不到她的声音。
One of the rescue workers holds up his fist to signal for silence. Everyone on site stands motionless, straining to listen for muffled signs of life from under what's left of the school. This is all being covered live and broadcast all over the country.
其中一名救援人员举起拳头示意安静。现场的所有人纹丝不动，努力倾听从学校废墟下发出的微弱生命迹象。这一切都在现场直播，并向全国广播。
They hear a tiny voice poking out.
他们听到一个微小的声音露出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
This rescue worker tells Danielle, I heard a very weak voice that belonged to a little girl named Sofia. Danielle asks him, did she say her name? And he says, yeah, I asked her, is your name Sophie? And she said, Sophie. Sophie.
这个救援人员告诉丹妮尔，我听到一个非常微弱的声音，属于一个叫索菲亚（Sofia）的小女孩。丹妮尔问他，她说了她的名字吗？他说，是啊，我问她，你叫索菲吗？她说，索菲。索菲。
The workers keep talking to the girl. They learn her full first name is Frida Sofia. And she's 12 years old. The Navy asks around for someone who knows Frida, a teacher or a family member, to try to make her feel more comfortable.
工作人员继续和那个女孩交谈。他们得知她的全名是弗里达·索菲亚（Frida Sofia）。她12岁。海军四处寻找认识弗里达的人，老师或家人，试图让她感觉更舒服。
The principal of the school, Monica Garcia Villegas, she survived the collapse. So did her daughter, who's also named Monica. She's a teacher at the school. They're both they're trying to help the rescue efforts.
学校校长莫妮卡·加西亚·维列加斯（Monica Garcia Villegas）在坍塌中幸存下来。她的女儿也幸存下来，也叫莫妮卡。她是学校的一名老师。她们都在那儿试图帮助救援工作。
Monica, the daughter, offers to talk to Frida. She crouches near the wall where Frida's trapped. She calls her princesa and Evita, terms of endearment. Frida responds, telling her that she's tired.
莫妮卡，也就是女儿，主动提出和弗里达交谈。她在弗里达被困的墙边蹲下。她称她为“公主”和“宝贝”，这些亲昵的称呼。弗里达回应了，告诉她她累了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Danielle explains that Televisa's withholding Frida's last name out of respect for the family's privacy.
丹妮尔解释说，Televisa为了尊重家人的隐私，隐瞒了弗里达的姓氏。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Frida has said that there are two bodies near her, but that she doesn't know if they're alive or who they are.
弗里达说她身边有两具尸体，但她不知道她们是否活着或者她们是谁。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Televisa reports that rescuers have gotten a phone to Frida. She's been able to send messages to the school principal. The whole country becomes emotionally involved with this girl. People are donating supplies and posting all over Twitter and Facebook about her. There's a hashtag, #FridaSofia. One person tweets, "She moved her hand, moved Mexico's heart." Another says, "Retweet if you're not going to sleep until you see Frida Sofia out of the rubble."
Televisa报道说救援人员已经把一部手机交给了弗里达。她能够向校长发信息。整个国家都与这个女孩在情感上联系在了一起。人们在捐赠物资，并在推特和脸书上到处发布关于她的消息。有一个标签，#FridaSofia。一个人发推特说，“她动了手，动了墨西哥的心。”另一个人说，“如果你不到看见弗里达·索菲亚从废墟中出来就不睡觉，就转发。”
She's the coverage of the earthquake. She becomes the center of all the earthquake stories.
她是地震的报道中心。她成了所有地震故事的核心。
That's Laura Tejero Nunez, a filmmaker who made a documentary about this.
那是劳拉·特杰罗·努涅斯（Laura Tejero Nunez），一位拍过关于此事的纪录片的电影制片人。
Everyone's talking about it. It's like a minute by minute. Everyone's following every step of Frida's rescue. Like when they leave their houses, when they leave their couches, they are like, well, what's up with Frida? Is she out yet?
每个人都在谈论它。就像逐分钟更新一样。每个人都在关注弗里达救援的每一步。比如当他们离开家，离开沙发时，他们会问，弗里达怎么样了？她出来了吗？
We know that there's been other victims, that other areas of Mexico have been strongly affected. But Frida is the center of all the eyes. Because she's also a story of hope.
我们知道还有其他受害者，墨西哥的其他地区也受到了强烈影响。但弗里达是所有目光的中心。因为她也是一个希望的故事。
Everyone's waiting to see what's going to happen. And then finally, word spreads of good news. A rescue worker on site says, she's been rescued. This was shot on a cell phone by someone standing outside the school.
每个人都在等待看会发生什么。然后终于，传来了好消息。现场的一名救援人员说，她被救出来了。这是某人站在学校外用手机拍下的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
She's OK, he says. She has vital signs. Televisa doesn't report the rescue. Presumably, they couldn't confirm it. Another reporter tweets that it's just a rumor. But then the Secretary of Education goes on the news.
她没事，他说。她有生命体征。Televisa没有报道这次营救。据推测，他们无法证实。另一名记者发推特说这只是谣言。但随后教育部长上了新闻。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He doesn't say she's been rescued. But he does say if you're Frida Sofia's parents or related to her, please come to the school. The city is in complete disarray, and lots of people are missing. This call for her parents rips across social media.
他没说她被救出来了。但他确实说，如果你是弗里达·索菲亚的父母或与她有亲属关系，请来学校。城市一片混乱，很多人失踪了。这个呼唤她父母的消息在社交媒体上疯狂传播。
And then the story takes another turn. Here's Laura the filmmaker again.
然后故事发生了另一个转折。这是电影制作人劳拉再次出镜。
So the earthquake is the 19th. We hear about Frida the morning of the 20th. And it's about 30 hours later, like the 21st of September, that the rescue authorities say that Frida never existed. The story of Frida Sofia is a lie.
所以地震是19号。我们听说弗里达是在20号早上。大约30小时后，也就是9月21日，救援当局说弗里达从来没存在过。弗里达·索菲亚的故事是个谎言。
No Frida Sofia was enrolled at the Enrique Rebsamen School. There is no Frida. The way everyone finds this out, the head of the Navy, the guy who's been giving, essentially, minute by minute updates on national television about Frida's condition, he goes on TV and gives this awkward press conference.
没有“弗里达·索菲亚”在恩里克·雷布萨门学校（Enrique Rebsamen School）注册。没有弗里达。每个人发现这件事的方式是，海军负责人，那个一直在全国电视上提供弗里达情况逐分钟更新的人，他上了电视并举行了那场尴尬的新闻发布会。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He says that Frida Sofia is not a reality.
他说弗里达·索菲亚不是一个现实。
That seems like very specific word choice.
那似乎是非常具体的用词选择。
Yeah, like he wanted to say like, oh, this wasn't a reality. I'm not going to say that anyone told lies. I'm not going to say that this wasn't true. Because that sounds much worse. I think he was aware of how big the idea of Frida had become, how prescient in the minds of the Mexicans she had become. And he knew that he was going to be accused of falsehoods.
是啊，好像他想说，哦，这不是一个现实。我不会说任何人撒谎了。我不会说这不是真的。因为那听起来更糟。我想他意识到了弗里达的想法已经变得多么巨大，她在墨西哥人的心目中变得多么具有预见性。他知道他会受到虚假的指控。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Shortly afterwards, Danielle Dithurbide, the reporter, comes out in Televisa saying that there is no girl called Frida Sofia. So she's not very straightforward on what's happening. She just kind of waters it down.
不久之后，记者丹妮尔·迪图尔比德在Televisa上出来说，没有叫弗里达·索菲亚的女孩。所以她对发生的事情不是很直接。她只是有点淡化了它。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then she says that she has gotten all the information from the authorities. So she kind of is-- do you say guarding her back? No. She's kind of--
然后她说她从当局那里得到了所有信息。所以她有点——你说是在保护自己吗？不。她有点——
Protecting herself. Like I didn't spread this. I just heard from the authorities.
保护自己。就像我没有散布这个消息。我只是从当局那里听到的。
Yeah, exactly. Like I was giving official information.
是啊，完全正确。就像我是在提供官方信息。
So after the news of Frida breaks, what happens?
所以弗里达的新闻爆出后，发生了什么？
The audience is furious. They are really mad. The social media is burning, like with hate messages towards Televisa. They accuse them of creating lies, spreading lies of literally having made up a character for everyone to follow to increase their ratings.
观众暴怒。他们真的非常生气。社交媒体在燃烧，比如对Televisa充满仇恨的信息。他们指责他们编造谎言，散布谎言，为了增加收视率，字面上编造了一个角色让所有人关注。
People sent Danielle, the Televisa reporter, hate mail and death threats. A few of the rescue workers said it was clear all along that Frida didn't exist, like Felipe, who you heard earlier.
人们给Televisa记者丹妮尔寄去仇恨邮件和死亡威胁。一些救援人员说，很明显弗里达一直不存在，比如你之前听到的费利佩。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I yelled out that that was a great lie. That there was no such Frida.
我大喊那是个天大的谎言。根本没有弗里达这个人。
Felipe said he was one of the people who'd made the hole where everyone thought Frida was trapped. He says he tried to tell people at the time that Frida wasn't real-- Danielle, authorities from the Navy.
费利佩说他是制造大家认为弗里达被困的那个洞的人之一。他说他在当时试图告诉人们弗里达不是真的——丹妮尔，来自海军的当局。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I told them, look, if you don't believe me, let's all go together in the hole. We are the ones who dug the hole. We explored absolutely everything in the area. And there is no small person there.
我告诉他们，看，如果你们不相信我，让我们一起去洞里。我们是挖掘那个洞的人。我们探索了该区域的一切。那里根本没有小人。
It didn't seem to matter.
这似乎没关系。
It was as though they didn't like it. The Televisa lady didn't like it. The Red Cross didn't like it, and neither did the Admiral.
就好像他们不喜欢这样。Televisa女士不喜欢，红十字会不喜欢，海军上将也不喜欢。
What do you mean they didn't like it?
你是什么意思他们不喜欢它？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
They didn't like it because I told them that everything they were saying was lies.
他们不喜欢是因为我告诉他们他们所说的一切都是谎言。
I called up Danielle, the Televisa reporter. She said she has no memory of talking to Felipe or of anyone telling her Frida wasn't real before the Navy broke the news.
我打电话给Televisa记者丹妮尔。她说她不记得和费利佩谈过，也不记得在海军爆出消息之前有任何人告诉她弗里达不是真的。
He said he invited you into the hole with him, and he said like, I'll show you she's not there. Do you remember anyone inviting you into the hole?
他说他邀请你和他一起去洞里，他说，比如，我会给你看她不在那里。你记得有人邀请你进洞吗？
No, that's not true. No, that's absolute-- that's a complete lie. That's not true. I swear on my life on it. That's not true.
不，那不是真的。不，那绝对是——那是一个完全的谎言。那不是真的。我以我的生命发誓。那不是真的。
When the Navy Undersecretary Sarmiento said Frida wasn't real, he also denied ever telling reporters that she was, which made Danielle furious. She saw him saying that to another reporter just a few feet away from her.
当海军副部长萨米恩托说弗里达不是真的时，他也否认曾告诉记者她是真的，这让丹妮尔暴怒。她看到他在离她几英尺远的地方对另一名记者那样说。
I mean, if I'm you, I feel like I would want to run over there, and--
我是说，如果我是你，我觉得我会想冲过去，并且——
And kill him. Kill him. Kill him. Yes, exactly. That was my exact feeling. I wanted to kill him.
然后杀了他。杀了他。杀了他。是的，完全正确。那是我的真实感受。我想杀了他。
Later on TV, the Navy Undersecretary apologized. He said Danielle was right. He had passed on wrong information. We reached out to the Navy multiple times, by the way, but never got clearance to do an interview.
后来在电视上，海军副部长道歉了。他说丹妮尔是对的。他传达了错误的信息。顺便说一下，我们多次联系海军，但从没获得采访许可。
Who do you think started the Frida myth?
你认为是谁开始了这个弗里达神话？
I don't know. I've been thinking about it for one year and a half, and I don't have any answer.
我不知道。我已经想了一年半了，我没有答案。
I don't have an answer either. But here's what I do know. Let's go detail by detail. The motion sensor and thermal scanner that detected Frida's body heat and movement, that technology can be imprecise. The movement it detected, that could just be the rubble shifting. The body heat it detected, that could be a piece of metal that's just exposed to the sun, and therefore warmer than the things around it.
我也没有答案。但这是我知道的。让我们细节对细节来看。探测弗里达体温和运动的运动传感器和热成像扫描仪，那项技术可能不精确。它探测到的运动，可能只是废墟在移动。它探测到的体温，可能是一块暴露在阳光下的金属片，因此比周围的东西更热。
As for the workers who heard Frida's voice, well, rescue workers pulled the body of a 58-year-old woman from the rubble after they'd talked to Frida. Maybe it had been her voice they had heard. Though her name wasn't Frida Sofia, it was Reyna Dávila.
至于听到弗里达声音的工作人员，嗯，救援人员在和弗里达谈话后，从废墟中拉出了一名58岁女性的遗体。也许他们听到的就是她的声音。虽然她的名字不是弗里达·索菲亚，而是雷娜·达维拉（Reyna Dávila）。
Or maybe the name Frida Sofia came from somewhere else. There was a Sofia there. She was one of the kids rescued earlier in the day. And there was a Frida on sight, too, a rescue dog helping to look for victims. I have no idea if that explains anything.
或者弗里达·索菲亚这个名字来自其他地方。那里确实有一个索菲亚。她是当天早些时候被救出的孩子之一。现场也有一个“弗里达”，一只协助寻找受害者的搜救犬。我不知道那是否能解释什么。
There are some details that no matter how I turn it, just don't seem like mistakes, like the cell phone and the text messages. A volunteer told the press that story. I couldn't find him to follow up. And that rescue worker who told the public that Frida had been rescued, we looked all over for him. Couldn't find him anywhere. Felipe, that rescue worker I talked to, he feels like, of course, I couldn't find the answer.
有些细节无论我怎么转动，看起来都不像是错误，比如手机和短信。一名志愿者告诉媒体那个故事。我没能找到他跟进。那个告诉公众弗里达被救出的救援人员，我们到处找他。在哪儿都找不到。费利佩，那个我谈过的救援人员，他觉得，当然，我找不到答案。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
These are people that like to show up on TV, those people that enjoy telling lies, and people that just don't like to accept the truth.
这些人喜欢在电视上露面，那些喜欢撒谎的人，以及那些根本不喜欢接受真相的人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I really can't explain to myself how it is that this was made up.
我真的无法向自己解释这是如何编造出来的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I imagine that this was the smokescreen, the whole Frida situation, in order to detour or to mask up the information. Merely a distraction.
我想象这就是烟雾弹，整个弗里达的情况，为了绕道或者掩盖信息。仅仅是一个分心。
He means a distraction from the person who's taken a lot of blame for the school collapse. Remember the Monicas? The principal of the school and her daughter, who worked there as a teacher and who said she talked to Frida. The principal, Monica García Villegas, she's also the owner of the school. It's a private school, and she lived there with the rest of her family.
他的意思是分心，不让人们关注对学校倒塌负有很多责任的人。记得那些莫妮卡吗？学校校长和她的女儿，她在那里当老师，并说她和弗里达谈过话。校长莫妮卡·加西亚·维列加斯（Monica García Villegas）也是学校的业主。那是一所私立学校，她和她的家人住在那里。
The building was originally just two stories, but they built two more stories on top and made that their apartment. The principal used all these heavy materials in the construction. She built marble floors and granite countertops. She added a new terrace, but didn't add any columns underneath to support it. She installed a Jacuzzi. When the earthquake hit, all of that overwhelmed the bottom two floors of the building, and it crumbled. It was likely the principal's apartment that killed 19 kids and at least seven adults.
这座建筑最初只有两层，但他们在上面又盖了两层，并把它变成了他们的公寓。校长在施工中使用了所有这些沉重的材料。她建造了大理石地板和花岗岩台面。她增加了一个新的露台，但下面没有增加任何支撑它的柱子。她安装了一个按摩浴缸。地震发生时，所有这一切压垮了建筑的最底层两层，它坍塌了。很可能是校长的公寓导致了19名儿童和至少7名成人死亡。
The principal fled the scene shortly after the school fell, though not before her daughter and other family members had recovered some of their valuables from the rubble, like purses and shoes, their car, a Mercedes Benz, and a bathtub they got four of the rescue workers to carry for them.
校长在学校倒塌后不久就逃离了现场，但她的女儿和其他家庭成员在废墟中找回了一些贵重物品，比如钱包和鞋子，他们的汽车，一辆奔驰车，和一个浴缸，他们让4名救援人员为他们搬运。
Authorities offered a five million peso reward to anyone who could find her. After nearly two years, the principal was finally arrested on charges of manslaughter in early May of this year. I reached out to her for a comment, but never heard back.
当局为能找到她的人提供了500万比索的悬赏。近两年后，校长终于在今年5月初因过失杀人罪被捕。我联系了她请求评论，但从未收到回复。
If the principal and her daughter knew all along that they didn't have a student named Frida Sofia, if the daughter was just pretending to talk to someone trapped under the rubble, if the Navy, for some reason, was passing along unfounded details to the press, or if the deception was more innocent-- volunteers hoping for the best and spreading rumors-- it all fell on willing ears. Hundreds of people had been killed by the earthquake. Lots more were still missing. Of course people wanted a little girl to root for.
如果校长和她的女儿一直都知道他们没有一个叫弗里达·索菲亚的学生，如果女儿只是假装在和被困在废墟下的人谈话，如果海军出于某种原因一直在向媒体传递毫无根据的细节，或者如果欺骗更无辜一些——志愿者希望最好并散布谣言——这一切都落在了愿意听的耳朵里。地震导致数百人丧生。还有更多人失踪。当然，人们想要一个值得支持的小女孩。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our show.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - LITTLE JACKIE, "TO THE RESCUE"]
[音乐 - 小杰基（Little Jackie），“去营救”]
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan with Elna Baker. The people who put this show together today includes Bim Adewunmi, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Hilary Elkins, Damien Grave, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, [INAUDIBLE] Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）和埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）制作。今天制作这个节目的人包括 Bim Adewunmi, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Hilary Elkins, Damien Grave, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney 和 Julie Whitaker。我们的主编是黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
Aviva DeKornfeld, who did the last story in the show, that last act, has been our production fellow for the last six months. The fellowship is now over. This is our last new show with her. She is super capable. We are sorry to see her go. Podcasters of America, you heard that story. Give her a job.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld），做了节目中的最后一个故事，那一幕，在过去六个月里一直是我们节目的制作研究员。奖学金现在结束了。这是我们和她一起制作的最后一档新节目。她超级能干。我们很遗憾看到她离开。美国的播客们，你们听到了那个故事。给她一份工作吧。
Special thanks today to Jose Acevedo, Yannos Misitzis, Jason Krouse, Rose Kue, Linda and Laura Xiong, Jackie Stevens, David Wilson, Calleigh McRaith, Lor Xiong-Roby, See Yang, Steve Bansbach, the Customs and Border Protection Chicago field office, Tesia Williams, Andrea Helling, Mark Greenberg, Bell Woods, Zoe Mendelson, Diego Salazar, and Luke Malone.
今天特别感谢何塞·阿塞韦多（Jose Acevedo）、亚诺斯·米西齐斯（Yannos Misitzis）、杰森·克劳斯（Jason Krouse）、罗斯·奎（Rose Kue）、琳达和劳拉·雄（Linda and Laura Xiong）、杰基·史蒂文斯（Jackie Stevens）、戴维·威尔逊（David Wilson）、卡莉·麦克拉斯（Calleigh McRaith）、洛·雄-罗比（Lor Xiong-Roby）、塞·杨（See Yang）、史蒂夫·班斯巴赫（Steve Bansbach）、海关和边境保护局芝加哥现场办公室、泰西亚·威廉姆斯（Tesia Williams）、安德里亚·赫林（Andrea Helling）、马克·格林伯格（Mark Greenberg）、贝尔·伍兹（Bell Woods）、佐伊·门德尔松（Zoe Mendelson）、迭戈·萨拉查（Diego Salazar）和卢克·马隆（Luke Malone）。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He really believes in the power of a hero sandwich. No kidding. Ordered a whole bunch for this big meeting we were going to have this week with some public radio stations and told me--
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）传递给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。他真的相信英雄三明治的力量。不开玩笑。为我们本周要和一些公共广播电台开的大型会议订购了一大堆，并告诉我——
They mean business. But we've got a party of kickass heroes that's going to save the day.
他们是认真的。但我们有一群厉害的英雄要拯救世界。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。